well for more we're joined from istanbul
by DW correspondent dorian jones
so dorian the turkish foreign minister
saying he's vowing retaliation against
the US tariffs what's likely to follow
from a move like this well turkey can do
very little economically to retaliate
against the united states but it can
hurt washington strategically there are
US forces working with a Syrian Kurdish
militia just across the Turkish border
turkey considers that militia a
terrorist organization so it could ramp
up pressure on that militia and the US
forces there on top of that Washington
has been pushing and lobbying Ankara
very hard to comply with its new Iranian
sanctions Ankara major trading partner
with Iran is seen as key to Washington
in his success of putting pressure on
Iran for now on Quora said he will not
comply with those sanctions
he's very unlikely in the president
environment it will change that stance
well-draining meanwhile the Turkish
financier has been trying to reassure
the public but the reality is that the
currency has been tanking for months the
country has seen inflation at nearly 16
percent and now these American tariffs
what's the impact on ordinary Turks I
think for the moment it is complete
shock they've seen their currency
literally implode in front of them
beyond that I think that there will be
concerns that if this route of the
currency continues it could put pressure
on Turkish banks today there is meant to
be an emergency meeting between Turkey
Supervisory Board and turkeys banks to
discuss the car currency crisis but
beyond that there that the fact that
Turkey imports with nearly all of its
energy a much of a many other important
imports there will be the expectation of
a huge wave of inflation hitting Turkey
in the coming weeks and months on top of
that many big companies have borrowed
large amounts of money in foreign
currency loans future fears about the
future of those companies will be
increasingly a focus of attention and
with that the fear of growing
unemployment tough times ahead for
Turkey whatever happens well tough times
ahead as you say it's important to
mention though that the latest US
tariffs were imposed specifically in
response to turkeys prolonged
of America of an American pastor would
the government consider releasing this
man as a way out of its economic crisis
well this pastor Andrew Bronson has
become basically the center of a battle
of wills between the Turkish and u.s.
presidents both men polite betray
themselves with strong men and I think
neva will be prepared to back down even
though ad one is aware of the incredible
costs are costing his country but he's
presenting this as basically a battle
for the future of democracy he says that
this currency route is an attempt to
remove him from power and he's vowed to
resist this with that present rhetoric
it makes him very difficult for him to
step back reports say the Americans have
given Turkey a deadline of this
Wednesday to return Brunson with the
expectation of further sanctions they do
not comply the stakes are very high in
the coming days and pressure on the
press turkish president the back down
will grow all right our correspondent
Dorian Jones reporting from Istanbul
thank you